it's been nearly four months since hurricane Ian
made landfall the category 4 storm touched down
on Florida's Coast in late September leaving a
terrible path of destruction in its wake our Omar
villafranca caught up with some of those most
affected by the storm including boat owners and
the people who serve them and though on the road
to recovery there's still a lot more work to be
done the boat business at Stacy Stevens Marina in
St James City Florida went from recreational to
recovery after Hurricane Ian crashed on Shore
in late September it was heartbreaking to see
like 15 years of building up a business to be
wiped out and essentially I'd say even 24 hours
where you know one day it was good and then
the next day it was completely gone the only
charter boat fishing being done is by cranes
fishing badly damaged boats throwing dreaded
out of the marina these boats that are behind you
are any of them the boats that would regularly be
in your Marina not one many end up on Stevens
Marina which has now become a boat emergency
room where they're stacked cataloged and inspected
by insurance companies this new line of work has
allowed her to remain open and keep her employees
working this giant sailboat just lifted on Shore
will be loaded onto a flatbed where the hull is
carefully moved to a nearby Field in what used to
be Steven's palm tree nursery now turned into a
makeshift boat graveyard There Rose upon rows of
more than 200 vessels and some mini Yachts await
their fate it's still astounding how many vessels
are completely displaced in the mangroves just
pushed up in places they shouldn't be on people's
yards on people's lifts that weren't there and
as the cleanup continues in Southwest Florida
after the storm so I think the boat was kind of
coming this way Rob Maine found his neighbor's
65-foot boat taboo where it shouldn't be lodged
in his backyard After the Storm ripped it off
the dock yeah it was a complete total shock
it looked bigger than we'd ever thought the
boat looked because now it's halfway on land
and halfway in our backyard and it'll be there
a few more weeks there's a long waiting list
for boat towing services on Florida's Gulf Coast
Florida's Fish and Wildlife Commission tasked
with clearing these vessels says there are
more than 700 derelict boats in these Waters but
only two-thirds have been removed and for taboo's
owner Jim Bayer the price to pull out and fix
the damaged boat is too much I contacted them
and they said to lift that off there with a huge
barge in a crane was going to be sixteen thousand
two hundred dollars just just to lift out and
put it in the water the insurance company will
come and Tow taboo bone six is Intel Andres Rosado
has spent more than two months cleaning up Ian's
mess see ya thank you towing damaged boats left on
the water and underwater to land I really hope to
be busy maybe few more months it's hard to ex
say how how long we're going to be doing this
I hope it's as much time that we have to clean
these whole environments but like many in this
part of Florida Rosado just wants to get back to
when being on the water wasn't work I do want to
be back towards the normal and that was boaters
going and join restaurants enjoying the beach
enjoying Southwest Florida for CBS Saturday
morning Omar via Franca St James City Florida
those are the stories like it's the months
later yes and even the years later for so
many places that a lot of people don't hear
about no it's not over the two weeks after
most news crews leave is right people
in the towns like it's tough to find
those good stories but they're important yeah the
cleanup continues uh Bravo to Omar thanks so much